Hace 10 000 años
apareció un virus mortal
en el noreste de África.
El virus se propagó por el aire,
atacando las células de la piel,
la médula ósea,
el bazo
y los ganglios linfáticos de sus víctimas.
Los desafortunados infectados
tuvieron fiebre,
vómitos
y erupciones cutáneas.
El 30 % de los infectados murió
en la segunda semana de la infección.
Los sobrevivientes quedaron
con cicatrices y secuelas
para el resto de sus vidas.
Había llegado la viruela.
En 1350 a.C., la primera
epidemia de viruela
azotó durante la guerra egipcio-hitita.
Los prisioneros egipcios
transmitieron la viruela
a los hititas,
quienes con ella mataron a su rey
y devastaron su civilización.
Insidiosa, la viruela se abrió
camino en todo el mundo
mediante los comerciantes egipcios,
luego en el mundo árabe con las cruzadas,
hasta llegar a América
con los conquistadores
españoles y portugueses.
Desde entonces, ha matado
a miles de millones de personas
con un estimado de 300 a 500
millones de personas
muertas solo en el siglo XX.
Pero la viruela no es imbatible.
De hecho, la caída de la viruela empezó
mucho antes de la medicina moderna.
Todo empezó allá por el 1022 d.C.
Según un pequeño libro titulado
"El tratamiento correcto de la viruela",
una monja budista que vivía
en una montaña famosa
llamada O Mei Shan
en la sureña provincia de Sichuan
molía costras de viruela
y soplaba ese polvo en la nariz
de las personas sanas.
Lo hizo después de notar
que quienes lograban
sobrevivir a la viruela
nunca la contraían nuevamente
y su extraño tratamiento funcionó.
El procedimiento, llamado variolación,
evolucionó lentamente
y a principios de 1700
los médicos tomaban material de las llagas
y lo ponían en personas sanas
mediante 4 o 5 rasguños en el brazo.
Esto funcionó bastante bien
dado que las personas inoculadas
no volvían a infectarse,
pero no era infalible.
Hasta un 3 % de las personas
seguía muriendo
luego de ser expuesto al pus.
Fue así hasta que
el médico inglés Edward Jenner
notó algo interesante en las ordeñadoras
y tuvimos la solución moderna.
A los 13 años, mientras
Jenner era aprendiz
de cirujano y boticario rural
en Sodbury, cerca de Bristol,
oyó a una ordeñadora decir:
"Nunca tendré la viruela
porque tuve viruela bovina.
Nunca tendré un rostro
picado por la fea viruela".
La viruela bovina
es una enfermedad de la piel
que se asemeja a la viruela
e infecta a las vacas.
Más tarde, como médico,
se dio cuenta de que ella tenía razón.
Las mujeres que tuvieron viruela bovina
no contrajeron la letal viruela.
Los virus de la viruela humana
y vacuna son de la misma familia.
Pero cuando un virus infecta
a un huésped desconocido,
en este caso la viruela
bovina a un humano,
es menos virulenta,
por eso Jenner decidió probar
si el virus de la viruela bovina
podía usarse
para protegerse de la viruela.
En mayo de 1796 Jenner
encontró una joven ordeñadora,
Sarah Nelmes,
que tenía lesiones frescas
de viruela bovina en la mano y el brazo,
que contrajo de las ubres
de una vaca llamada Blossom.
Con la materia de sus pústulas
inoculó a James Phipps,
el hijo de 8 años de su jardinero.
Luego de unos días de fiebre y malestar
el chico parecía recuperarse.
Dos meses después,
Jenner inoculó al chico nuevamente;
esta vez con materia
de una lesión fresca de viruela.
No desarrolló la enfermedad,
y Jenner concluyó
que la protección era total.
Su plan funcionó.
Jenner luego usó
el virus de la viruela bovina
en varias personas más
y las desafió reiteradas veces con viruela,
demostrando que eran
inmunes a la enfermedad.
Con este procedimiento,
Jenner inventó
la vacuna contra la viruela.
A diferencia de la variolación,
que usaba el virus de la viruela real
para tratar de proteger a las personas,
la vacunación usaba el mucho menos
peligroso virus de la viruela bovina.
El orden médico establecido,
tan prudente entonces como ahora,
deliberó largamente sobre sus hallazgos
antes de aceptarlos.
Pero con el tiempo la vacunación
fue aceptada gradualmente
y la variolación se prohibió
en Inglaterra en 1840.
Luego de grandes campañas de vacunación
a lo largo de los siglos XIX y XX,
la Organización Mundial
de la Salud certificó
la erradicación de la viruela en 1979.
Jenner es recordado
como el padre de la inmunología,
pero no nos olvidemos
de la ordeñadora Sarah Nelmes,
de la vaca Blossom,
ni de James Phipps,
todos héroes en esta
gran aventura de la vacunación
que ayudó a erradicar la viruela.